the Deputy Attorney General apparently
knew about President Trump's plan to
fire FBI director James Comey before
writing a memo recommending his
dismissal senator said rod Rosenstein
indicated that during a closed-door
briefing yesterday his memo criticized
Comey for how he handled the
investigation of Hillary Clinton's
emails the White House said President
Trump based his decision to fire combing
on that memo Rosenstein will brief
members of the House later today CBS
News chief Washington correspondent and
Face the Nation moderator John Dickerson
is with the junk good morning morning
Charlie so where are we in all of this
yeah surely uh where are we well okay we
were the president is obviously there
created a condition where something he
called a witch-hunt now has bipartisan
support robert muller has been praised
by Republicans and Democrats there's
that track going on the president's
trying to get the track and his team are
trying to get back to what there should
be talking about which is his domestic
agenda and he's about to go take this
big foreign trip which they've spent a
lot of time working on and which gives
him an opportunity to put himself on the
print on the world stage and put forward
his his agenda for the world we got to
see three investigations at the same
time the House the Senate and the
special gas that's right and you've got
House and Senate intelligence committees
plus the Judiciary Committee and they
all want a piece of this to talk to
James Comey they want to see those memos
there are more than one and they want to
hear from him as well and then of course
you've got the special counsel which
will always be out there bouncing along
new possible revelations but also
reminding everyone that the president
has now has this narrative or this these
conversations you had with Comey which
are different and separate and a
different problem than the Russia
investigation or their tapes well are
their tapes and also how detailed are
these memos because the key question is
did the president know what he was doing
or was he just an inexperienced guy
saying the Comey hey can you stop being
so focused on this if it's true from the
papers that director Comey kept telling
him look we shouldn't be having these
conversations and yet he persisted then
that gets you into a condition where the
president is knowingly doing something
rather than just being an inexperienced
guy who doesn't know the particularity
of the way you're supposed to behave the
president seems to be at odds with rod
Rosenstein in terms of the importance of
the memo that rod Rosenstein wrote in
the firing of James Comey right well the
Rosen sign Stein memo which is the one
that first the way
have said this is why the president made
his decision now we've learned now the
president was going to do this anyway
and the reason that's a problem is that
it's it's not only it's a ragged story
exactly why did you do this mr.
president but it also puts Rosenstein on
the hook a little bit his reputation was
referred to several times in explaining
why this really had nothing to do with
politics because he is he is supported
by Republicans and Democrats but then
when it looks like the letter might be a
cover for another reason that Comey was
fired that's what creates credibility
problems that go outside the president
and spread into his administration by
all accounts this has been a very bad
week for the Trump administration what
are you hearing from his supporters
about how they feel about the job he's
doing and how this is all info his
supporters feel like he's doing a great
job he's in there swinging and fighting
for them you see no genius and why not
not really I mean because for a couple
of reasons one they see the challenges
he has as more proof that there is this
swamp he's trying to get fight through
they hear him when he says look I got
this deal with China to get beef sold in
China for the first time since 2004 they
think the press is against him and and
the reason this is important is that
it's a feedback mechanism because the
president hears this and says these are
the people who supported me they're the
ones who got me into office if I'm okay
with them I can continue doing what I'm
doing forget the all this great on the
other hand within the White House we
keep hearing reports there will be a
staff shake-up there will be a staff
shake-up right and then you talk to
other people in the White House and say
all those stories are overblown which in
the old days when covering other
administrations the minute they tell you
that the stories are overblown is about
20 minutes before those those snap shake
up sap so it's quite hard to say but
there is a lot of talk about that and
and from our own reporting and so I
suspect something's coming yeah I never
think it's good when the word embattled
is used in front of your name to me that
the clock is ticking thank you John
always good to see you